it's midnight and all is still
except for the soft skittering of a
gecko hunting a spider
gecko seem to defy gravity scaling
vertical surfaces and walking upside
down without claws adhesive goos or
super-powered spider webs
instead they take advantage of a simple
principle
that positive and negative charges
attract
that attraction binds together compounds
like table salt which is made of
positively charged sodium ions stuck to
negatively charged chloride ions
but a gecko's feet aren't charged and
neither are the surfaces they're walking
on
so what makes them stick
the answer lies in a clever combination
of intermolecular forces and structural
engineering
all the elements in the periodic table
have a different affinity for electrons
elements like oxygen and fluorine really
really want electrons
while elements like hydrogen and lithium
don't attract them as strongly
in atom's relative greed for electrons
it's called its electronegativity
electrons are moving around all the time
and can easily relocate to wherever
they're wanted most
so when there are atoms with different
electronegativities in the same molecule
the molecule's cloud of electrons gets
pulled towards the more electronegative
atom
that creates a thin spot in the electron
cloud where positive charge from the
atomic nuclei shines through as well as
a negatively charged lump of electrons
somewhere else
so the molecule itself isn't charged but
it does have positively and negatively
charged patches
these patchy charges can attract
neighboring molecules to each other
they'll line up so that the positive
spots on one are next to the negative
spots on the other
there doesn't even have to be a strongly
electronegative atom to create these
attractive forces
electrons are always on the move and
sometimes they pile up temporarily in
one spot that flicker of charge is
enough to attract molecules to each
other
such interactions between uncharged
molecules are called van der waals
forces
they're not as strong as the
interactions between charged particles
but if you have enough of them they can
really add up
that's the gecko secret
gecko toes are padded with flexible
ridges those ridges are covered in tiny
hair-like structures much thinner than
human hair called ct
and each of the ct is covered in even
tinier bristles called spatulae
their tiny spatula-like shape is perfect
for what the gecko needs them to do
stick and release on command when the
gecko unfurls its flexible toes onto the
ceiling the spatula hit at the perfect
angle for the van der waals force to
engage
the spatulae flatten creating lots of
surface area for their positively and
negatively charged patches to find
complementary patches on the ceiling
each spatula only contributes a
minuscule amount of that van der waals
stickiness
but a gecko has about 2 billion of them
creating enough combined force to
support its weight
in fact the whole gecko could dangle
from a single one of its toes
that super stickiness can be broken
though by changing the angle just a
little bit
so the gecko can peel its foot back off
scurrying towards a meal or away from a
predator
this strategy using a forest of
specially shaped bristles to maximize
the van der waals forces between
ordinary molecules has inspired man-made
materials designed to imitate the
gecko's amazing adhesive ability
artificial versions aren't as strong as
gecko toes quite yet
but they're good enough to allow a
full-grown man to climb 25 feet up a
glass wall
in fact our gecko's prey is also using
van der waals forces to stick to the
ceiling
so the gecko peels up its toes and the
chase is back on
you